[Music]
thank you for joining this session where
I get to be the messenger to the team's
great work in accomplishing an amazing
migration actually there's been a single
thread that's been common among all the
leaders and the decision makers that
I've been talking with in the past week
and that is that there's always one
thing one thing that leads up to the
decision and one thing that leads up to
the the catalyst to be able to actually
make the decision to move to cloud and
for us this was it it was a moment of
clarity when our head of IT delivered
this message to me and funny enough my
five-year-old son at home he came to me
and he saw this slide he said oh my gosh
daddy what happened and I said don't
worry don't worry daddy's not gonna let
that happen so what are we gonna talk
about we're gonna talk about all the
decisions that led up to us migrating to
cloud and why we decided on Google cloud
we're gonna talk about our initial plans
and you know what things change so we're
also going to talk about what actually
really happened just a reminder for the
folks that don't know Volusion we are an
all-in-one commerce platform or a SAS
platform and we are the only ones in the
industry that are focused on SMBs and
the Small Business Administration
defines SMBs in many different ways in
the one fact or the metric that stands
out to me is the fact that SMB is making
generally less than 50 million annually
those are our customers at the heart of
everything that we do is our culture
code and in fact we reinvented it a
couple years ago and one of the most
important slides in our culture code
that drives every decision we make is
that question what's in it for the
customer and if you saw PHS session
yesterday about being the customer
that's what we're talking about here and
if you wanted to check out more on our
culture code please go to culture at
Volusion calm
hopefully it influences you like we were
influenced to create it in the first
place
just a point of clarity we actually have
two offerings for Volusion we have what
we refer to internally as V 1 and V 2 so
V 2 is modern in the cloud it's our new
offering but for the purposes of this
session we're gonna focus on V 1 what is
V 1 it's a software that's been pretty
much in development since 1999 it's got
a lot of code it's predominantly Windows
I is Microsoft sequel server and the
team over the years has figured out how
to orchestrate and how to put customers
on different segments and different
groupings of iis and database depending
on the volume that they get so some
merchants get more traffic than others
and the isolation the teams figured out
over the years as an example we actually
have pretty huge traffic spikes for
certain customers in fact over a two or
three day period we experienced very
heavy loads and we call that period
Black Friday where our merchants get a
lot of shopper traffic so let's talk
about why cloud and why Google Cloud so
here's a picture actually this is
misleading
we had datacenter 0.1 which is the
founders bedroom closet
this is volution datacenter one oh and
one thing that you're gonna notice is
single points of failure single CPUs
single Network single disk and this is
actually a closet in one of the offices
but we evolved we learned we got better
and we went to a colocation in Simi
Valley California but you still see the
same problems single points of failure
single deadbolt security to get in
single network single power so the team
invested in a tier 4 colocation and
that's based in Austin Texas and it's
phenomenal the security is amazing the
redundancy on power and cooling is
amazing and in fact the initial proposal
from the team was let's move everything
from Simi Valley California to this tier
4 colocation and what that would mean is
sometimes you'd have to buy a bunch of
hardware so that you can move over the
summers and most of the apps can come
over but you might also have to acquire
some software along the way and then I
had to ask myself which is a question
that some of you here might be asking
yourselves which is should we be in the
data center business or what value what
our customers get from us being in the
data center business so we dug into the
facts and I found out something really
interesting that over 50% of our
failures were the result of hardware or
the interconnectivity between that
hardware within the data center we call
that network so we started to go to all
the calculators on all the major cloud
platforms and we started to scope out
what does it look like how much is it
going to cost for us to move over to the
cloud and initial savings could have
been somewhere around 20 to 21% so that
sounded good that's money that we can
use for R&D for our customers we could
repurpose that but how do you know which
cloud to use right there's so many
choices there's the big three and
there's tons more so it's really hard to
make that decision how do you choose
which ones right for you everyone has a
selection process every company has
their own mechanisms and frameworks for
us it was really simple we would get a
bunch of proposals from all the vendors
and all the cloud providers we would
spend some time evaluating we would do a
proof-of-concept perhaps during that
evaluation and then we would make a
decision and what happened was
phenomenal the best conversations that
we had were with the Google cloud team
in fact I'll give you an example we had
a major networking constraint that we
had to discuss and in 24 hours we as a
team got on a hangout with the team at
Google cloud that built the
infrastructure the networking
infrastructure on Google cloud and they
were able to answer our questions
directly and as another reference one of
the other cloud providers not to be
named sent us to a vendor who got back
to us in two weeks took two weeks just
to get back to us to have a phone call
so now we're kind of settling on Google
Cloud
what's our initial plan gonna be how do
we actually do that it's starting to
sound like it could fit once again that
all-important question that we asked
what's in it for the customer an uptime
is perhaps one of the most important
things our customers are SMBs these are
small medium businesses these are moms
and pops and if we go down they can't
make money to pay their mortgage their
employees sometimes this is their only
business is an online e-commerce store
so if we can eliminate hard wave
hardware failures and that graph I
showed you we'd get closer to even more
9s than 99.9 and we can scale on demand
so we can deal with that traffic that
spikes during Black Friday having
everybody on a homogeneous development
environment IT Engineering the data
teams the ops teams would be powerful
and we'd be able to speed up development
times having access to the same tools
and this would benefit the customer
because we'd get product shipped to them
a lot faster speaking of faster some of
the case studies on Google Google cloud
actually showed us that people are
benefiting from globe at the globally
available network that Google has and we
felt we could be faster than Network
could be faster just by moving over
there's so many other benefits I'm sure
you've read about and heard about him in
this next and last year's next and all
the collateral the one thing that stood
out to us was the access that we would
get to the Google cloud platform teams
and by the way when we started diving a
little bit deeper with the Google cloud
platform team we started to see a little
bit better cost to serve reduction so
the estimates were about 33% now that we
would save on monthly cost to serve that
we can reinvest in R&D so which
migration approach is right for us right
there's so many different ones these are
the three core ones that we were kind of
dabbling in and making a decision on and
on the far left there's the cloud native
approach which is kind of a complete
rewrite to match Google cloud platform
tools and technology all the way on the
right it's a little bit less work but
similar you leverage the cloud native
aspects both of those that I just
mentioned are pretty high effort and
high cost upfront but the savings are
huge and in the middle there's this
thing called lift and shift and lift and
shift just means move over as much as
you can with minimal modification and
that's what we decided to choose we want
what lift and shift and what that meant
is if we had an app server sitting in
our colocation and our data center
somewhere we would spin up an exact
instance like that in GCP and move it
over and we would only write code or
make changes if it didn't work if there
was impediments so that's cool we're
gonna do a lift and shift but how do you
actually do that so other people say it
usually better than than I can in this
case Benjamin Franklin said it best tell
me and I forget teach me and I remember
and involve me and I learned and that
last sentence is what's really important
to us as a company when you involve the
teams when you get buy-in when you get
that learning then everybody is actually
going to help move this thing forward
quicker and in fact the way that we
decided to learn up front was to engage
the experts and at at the time that we
decided to do this we we engaged Google
they had a program called Google cloud
start and they brought on their experts
to do infrastructure and architecture
planning and show us you know this is
how you do it and we got to learn from
them
and speaking of learning there was a lot
of ways that we could decide to learn
and choose to learn and we took
advantage of every single one of these
ways so we engaged professional services
once again the experts that have done
this before
we had workshops on-site and virtual for
the teams we had on-site training and
sometimes we had classes of 25 or more
people of Illusion years in those
training sessions learning about
different technologies that GCP has to
offer and at the time that we did this
there were no case studies there were
there was no other examples of any other
companies that have done this before so
we were we're kind of pioneer pioneering
away for a SAS platform SAS ecommerce
company to move over all these customers
with minimal downtime and we had a
pretty accelerated timeline to do that
we spent about one quarter making the
decision and planning we spent another
quarter actually doing the migration
itself we spent a couple months flipping
over the bits to get the customers live
and and then now we're in this phase
where we call modernization where we're
trying to take advantage of cloud native
technologies and I find it remarkable
that last year we were attendees to this
conference and this year we're talking
about how we actually did it that's a
fantastic achievement by the team so
that was the plan so what actually
really happened
problem number one because we host
thousands of websites that need
certificates there was no technology
that Google had natively cloud native to
be able to host and do SSL termination
on those certificates so this was the
first problem and we have over 50,000 of
them and the proposal that we had
approached during the cloud start phase
was a hybrid traffic layer using nginx
and if you don't know what engine X is
it's a reverse proxy layer an HTTP layer
that you can add in so we would still
leverage some of the the cloud the cloud
load balancer aspects of Google but we
had build this layer in between called
nginx and that would handle the SSL
hosting and the termination across all
the other layers all the way to the the
store resolution I think we had to
rebuild us a few times but eventually
this is what we settled on and we
internally refer to this as the three
layer cake it's a combination of
Google's Google Cloud at the top with
Google cloud load balancers and nginx
spread through the middle what's
fantastic about this is that different
teams across the company can focus on
their respective layers for example
InfoSec can focus on the security layer
and because it's abstracted out this way
they usually don't impact the other
layers the app engineering team can
focus on the bottom most layer problem
number two at the time that we were
going to do this migration we had to DNS
servers and we knew that that was going
to be a bottleneck
and the solution here was Google Cloud
DNS and in fact to our surprise the day
that we cut over our DNS to Google Cloud
DNS we saw a 15% improvement and first
byte response time on average across all
of our customer sites so that was a
fantastic win problem number three once
again because we are hosting all these
websites there's thousands of small
files CSS JavaScript images flat files
HTML files plus the database how do you
move all those over with minimal
downtime we actually leveraged the
combination of cloud indoor and our
internal scripts and cloud indoor has a
product called live migration
where it'll constantly do continuous
replication from our data center over to
Google cloud and only when we're ready
what it actually do the cutover
so this was a fantastic tool a little
bit deeper dive on that this is how we
did it every single night with minimal
maintenance window and minimal downtime
for our customers so we would update the
DNS record to point to the new Google
Cloud DNS we'd move all the files we had
update the nginx layer that we talked
about we'd move any last pieces of the
database and then the customer would be
live we did this all with a five to
fifteen minute minute maintenance window
per customer or per cluster of customers
so that was how we did it every single
night and I I believe it took us about
two and a half three weeks to get
through these nightly migrations so I'd
love to also share some of the successes
and the learnings we had along the way
sometimes code just doesn't work and in
fact we had over a hundred JIRA tickets
that we had filed before the migration
and there was some issues that we didn't
catch along the way but I'll give you an
example of what you'd look for anything
hard-coded IP anything hard-coded server
names anything hard-coded file shares
those are things that we would have to
change
we thought that by using multi-region
that we would be closer to the shoppers
and we'd be closer to the merchants but
that didn't necessarily work out the
right way because of the way that
Windows likes to route traffic and nginx
likes to route traffic and Linux likes a
triplet to route traffic that kind of
diversity caused saturation at the wine
layer and we had unpredictable traffic
patterns and by going to a single region
and we settled on central we're able to
get consistent performance and
predictable performance and then later
the team can decide on how to tweak and
tune that to make it faster and in fact
here's one of the tweaks that they did
so nginx by default it goes to http 100
which is stateless by turning on HTTP
1.1 persistent connections once again
with no code changes we were able to
deliver another 50 percent first byte
improvement on top of that 15 percent I
mentioned earlier it's a 50 percent
improvement on first byte no code change
we had we had a challenge on migration
latency basically moving all those
thousands of files over over the years
we built all these scripts and tools to
be able to shuffle customers around in
our internal data center infrastructure
and we just kind of thought that they
would work all these scripts would work
if we pointed the end the destination to
cloud and they didn't and that's where
cloud indoor came in some other things
that were pretty remarkable happen along
the way too because we had training and
learning and workshops at Volusion
other teams caught a glimpse of what the
power of GCP is and in this case the
marketing team they learned what what
all about nginx and they decided to use
nginx for a/b testing our dub-dub-dub
illusion comm site and there's a lot of
a/b testing tools out there but what we
were trying to do is pretty unique we
had a rebrand effort and during some
time during the migration these tools
came about and we were able to split
traffic from our classic non branded
site to the new branded site without
redirecting anyone to it
context path that means everybody stayed
on dub-dub-dub illusion calm they didn't
go to /b or /a and it was pretty smart
this layer in between we check the uri
string it would check query string it
would check cookies and it would persist
that user to that particular a/b test so
this was a great win and the marketing
team also decided to use buckets and
ghosts to host the blog so our our
previous version of the blog was
actually pretty slow and we didn't
realize it until we realized how fast it
was once we moved it over to GCP but
once we did move it over to Google cloud
and we took advantage of cloud CDN this
thing was blazing fast and it's gone
through a few more iterations now but
it's it's definitely a win dimension
here so as I mentioned first fight
response times have improved for our
customers by 65% with no code change and
we have been able to save even more
money than we originally forecasted
that's money that we can spend on
product development and R&D so right now
we are saving 37 percent
month-over-month on our cost to serve
and we feel like we're gonna keep going
down that path of saving more money and
what's in it for the customer here's a
quote from one of our customers Derek
operates a sporting goods store it's a
paintball store called ans gear the
quote is actually really long here
I'm gonna call attention to the parts
that you can't see which is the fact
that for the first time ever he was able
to run a marketing promotion 100% on our
platform without seeing any degradation
and performance of his response time on
his site and historically site traffic
goes up even a half-second latency
causes sales to to not go up or maybe
even dip that didn't happen on GCP at
all so this is a fantastic win for the
customer and kind of a you got to take a
step back and celebrate sometimes
celebrate your wins as a company and we
got a chance to do that both publicly
and internally we got to celebrate being
the first to my
to cloud and we had a big party
internally to celebrate the achievement
so if you only have to remember one
thing from this presentation
it's that whatever decision you make
whether you want to move to cloud
whether you're already on the cloud you
should ask yourself what's in it for the
customer and if you can remember a
couple things
it's that learning and persistence and
perseverance is how you get there
because there was so many times that we
could give up so many times it's easy to
say no we're not going to do that right
now we're just going to go to a Colo and
call it a day but it's that perseverance
attitude that's going to get you there
so thank you so much we have created an
email address for any questions
you
[Music]